[Music]
surprise
what the hell are we doing on here it's
Sunday it's a new show yeah yeah okay
like remember how we said and I think I
mentioned this on the last movie review
remember we said we were gonna wait
until we got $1,000 on patreon a month
before we started a third show way
nobody got to have it yeah we decided
that we're just gonna go ahead and do
put up another show I mean we got so we
got some like heavy hitters out there
supporters that are you know I mean
paint us on patreon we're not gonna let
them down
so we're gonna go ahead and we're gonna
do the third show yeah all right so what
we're gonna do since as I said a couple
weeks ago we've got this new AMC Stubbs
a list program where you pay 20 bucks a
month you go see three movies in the
theater a week so we decided well he
decided yes why don't we well we're
going to the movies anyway right he was
already recording little reviews anyway
for his Tom shitty movies Facebook page
I said let's do new movies so yeah let's
just do little caption reviews of new
movies when we see them in the theater
then we can take a list all that mileage
and all that booze and write that off of
our two exes like yeah oh so now we're
just gonna go ahead and open up a third
movie and we're gonna give you
recommendations on new movies that are
in the theaters now yeah and because now
we can see them and their most we can't
watch them all we can only watch 12 up
yeah but based on demographics and [ __ ]
they're probably the same movies you'd
be interested in yeah twelve them a
month half of we're not gonna be
interested in really fit yeah train I
mean it's like you know what I mean it's
what they're showing there is not you
know I'm Anthony generally we're gonna
stick like we do with our you know movie
rights recognized or thrilling
science-fiction action movies stuff like
that stuff we like so and justice would
you like yeah it seems like what you
guys like to so you know we're gonna go
and do that go see three movies a week
we'll probably do we'll probably do most
of the filming in the theater while
we're in there because you know we can
do our impressions like right after the
movie is over which we did on this first
episode too except for the bit on
Hellfest where we actually
reports um but we lost the video so we
had to like redo it right well we talked
about the movie but that's basically
what we're gonna do is gonna be like a
shitty little informal like shitty but
yeah we don't want to do it like real
formal right some of the other channels
do it it looks fake to me it also looks
like it's paid like paid advertisements
and sometimes they get so far deep into
it and so geeky into it I think it
almost compromises what what the
experience is actually like when you're
seeing it in the theater you know some
guys will pick a movie apart to my new
show and the average person really
doesn't experience the movie that way
when they're seeing it yeah we kind of
just wanted it to be like like you guys
were coming to the movie with us right
and then like after the movie was over
we were just like shooting the [ __ ]
about like what did you think about that
you know did you like this did you like
that just movie money right so we just
kind of wanted that sort of informal
like you were going to the movies this
type of feel
I can geek out on Star Wars and talk
about stars and [ __ ] to the minutia and
it would bore the average person that's
other channels let other channels do
that [ __ ] okay
this channel we're gonna be kind of did
we have a good time did what what did
the movie makes sense were you able to
follow it yeah you know what what kind
of experience was it was it where it
would have been worth ticket price
you know that's yeah I talk about
because seriously I'm not like I'm a
geek about a lot of things and I get
geeky about movies I like and things
like that but I'm not really like I'm
very willing to give movies the benefit
of the doubt
I don't like like to read about them
beforehand I like to just watch them and
be like okay take me somewhere and then
either I enjoyed the journey or I did
not I'm not gonna get all butthurt if I
didn't like it I'm not gonna be like oh
it raped my family or anything you know
what I mean I'm not gonna get like I'm
only like that with some IPS yeah it's
like but I just think it's it's a
pointless exercise it's like if I didn't
like and I'm like man you know well I
just won't see anymore by that director
or I just think you know and I just get
on with my life I don't really care so
I'm just gonna try to give it advice
that would help you as kind of like the
average viewer yeah and like I said
we're not gonna be able to see every
single movie because we can only see
three a week which I mean that's kind of
a lot but generally we're gonna stick
with will we'll generally try to see all
the horror movies
action movies all the sci-fi movies you
know we'll try and thrillers because I
like those really a few kids movies cuz
every now and then some of those kids
movies look like a Grich I kind of want
to see that graphic I kind of want to
seesaw Kristen I kinda want to see small
foot to get loaded and go to the good go
watch the Grinch that sounds like a
fantastic time we have to have some like
themed Christmas cocktails though we can
have like a bunch of Goths with us oh we
need to do that once the [ __ ] does that
movie start I know November I think okay
but yeah well over the coming weeks
we'll be seeing you know we'll be seeing
all the main boobs seen the new
Halloween will be seeing probably see
overlord and all the new ones that are
coming I already saw Mission Impossible
yeah we said yeah so yeah so that'll be
on this episode just after this
introduction so without further ado
here's our little ramshackle little
reviews that we've recorded at the
theater [ __ ] after seeing all of the
recent three movies that we saw this
week so please enjoy this third 13
o'clock show the 13 o'clock matinee take
all right Ginny and I are at AMC
Theaters it's actually kind of a quiet
day today Anna Jenny well it's Monday
Monday yeah yeah we're gonna see Mission
Impossible fall out got Tom Cruise I
like Tom Cruise
I like the boss on the arrogant prick
but I also think I also think Tom's kind
of sensitive yeah oh yeah that one is
near the dam invisible so I don't know
much about this movie I have seen um I
think I saw mission impossible 3 and
it's pretty good
but it's just a James Bond type movie
weirder for this theater 100k yeah yeah
they're just let's see if there's
anybody in here
I've seen she's only one other person
and it there so let's watch this thing
alright so we just got done seeing makes
Mission Impossible fall out it was good
I like Tom Cruise saves the entire world
yeah I don't think you appreciate how we
could just go about our daily lives
because Tom Cruise is out there with a
goatee goatee Bauer's saving the world
signs are doing in the name of the woods
IMF the International Monetary Fund is
OK was it possible mission impossible
mission force yeah I know they're not
CIA there's some kind of a contractors I
work for the CIA but they do like stuff
that's supposedly impossible like yeah
it's probably not gonna be here then
what you guys gonna do that but they
always do yeah it wasn't it was a cool
flick though I'm a big fan of James Bond
movies I liked the new Daniel Craig
James Bond and really this movie kind of
folded right in to that universe it's
that same genre there's mi6 in there and
stuff and really you could kind of
imagine that this has taken place in the
same universe as James Bond it's like a
slightly funnier James
well there's humour in it a little bit
more human like a comedy but there's one
yeah another thing that I noticed is
that there's just more in this yeah
James Bond is kind of dark and slick and
kind of low-key this one there's if you
like James Bond there's more in this
there's a lot more shootouts a lot more
chases more interesting guns I would say
the the the town is a little more brash
a little more positive you know well the
the situation is different all what's an
American in America it's an American
version of James Bond like not as slick
like you said but it's just kind of more
scrappy
yeah it's scrappy James yeah and I have
to say saying it is how I'm not like a
huge fan of top
or anything but it's like the whole
Scientology thing you know well we're
just taught to move right he's been it's
a movie yeah but I have to say that I
don't think that I saw any of the other
Mission Impossible movies I may have
seen the first one but I don't really
remember two or three but it was okay
say though that you know I mean this
story is even though it's like intrigue
and everything like that it's like a
complex story like a James Bond type
stories but I didn't have any trouble
following it even though I hadn't seen
any of the other ones you could watch
this as a stand against a--'s I assume
like back to the other movies yeah but
you don't need to have seen them because
they owe you enough to like figure okay
I thought I figured out who that is it's
definitely it is a dense plot but yeah
but you do have fun that's action-packed
really yeah the whole the whole thing
you know and I don't sometimes you kind
of lose what's going on inside of a
chance bond movie the first time you see
it so much it's like wait hold on what
happened that this moment this one
didn't really seem to do that I didn't
forever remember getting lost like it
seems like this one was but it's less
intricately plotted I think than a James
Bond movie it's like it's a pretty
straightforward story there's just kind
of like one mission it goes off on
tangents there's double and triple and
quadruple crosses yes person's not who
they're supposed to be and all this
other stuff like your standard spy movie
stuff but it's very I found it very easy
to follow like I said even though it
happened I don't think I've seen any of
it another thing I noticed is that you
know this is what if you like the new
James Bond movies you would like this
one and if you don't like the new James
Bond movies for some reasons you
probably would still like this because
I've heard some people knock the new
James Bond movies for not having enough
gadgets not having a lot of the stuff
that happened and some of the older
James Bond well that is actually in this
in these I'm a little gadget trees and
stuff like that yeah yeah yeah they had
that so
I mean Simon Pegg is in it and yeah so
in a way some of the stuff that is
lacking in the new James Bond series
actually is in this so in certain ways
this is kind of reminding some of the
retro James Bond films yeah almost kind
of like on all the James Bond but it's
done in that new style like you would
see in a right there and then like a
Craig style one thing I kind of always
because and maybe this is true of the
other you know I saw the TV series like
back in the day I was like but um which
was a little bit more comedic I don't
like it but one of the funniest things
to me in this is that every like you
know that every possible thing that
could go wrong is gonna go yeah you're
just like oh here we go one of course
and of course the whole thing happened
in that horrible yeah and there's
something so it's always kind that very
funny so still the movie worked I didn't
see it I didn't see it too much as being
a funny movie I guess she did but I
didn't I saw it was pretty serious
there was comedy in it it mostly there
was combat it's funny to me right there
are some characters in there that were
that had comedic you know qualities in
fact you know in fact Tom Cruise's
character you know he he thing he has a
sense of humor he does you got I am just
making this up that I'm deal there is
some of that in there you know but it's
not a comedy it's not a comedy yeah it's
basically it's it's a James Bond style
for action flick really yeah but yeah
what I loved it
it's really good to you and it's it's
long but it didn't seem like it's long
so it's like two and a half hours and
it's like it didn't seem like it kind of
kind of flew by I think I only really
had one gripe about the movie was that
there wasn't this there wasn't a single
gray hair and Tom Cruise's had that Tom
Cruise be his age I mean he's gotta be
pushing 60 and I think he would actually
look better if he had some gray hair
giving him some grup tea yeah it's
almost like sometimes you see him and
you know he's not a young man but it's
almost kind of like they're trying to
make him look a lot younger than he is
but they don't really have to because
he's in good shape they don't have you
know yeah I think I think you know I
think if anything I think girls have to
look pretty
I actually I would think I would think
that that character would look better
with like silver hair yeah if you had
silver white hair I think I think it
would look because he doesn't look like
an old man but you can tell you but he's
not on it but he's not a young guy and
and you say well wait you don't have a
single gray hair and you know you're
dyeing your hair your secret agent you
die in your head goddamn look at it's
coming down it is just coming down oh my
god just started since we got out we
just like sat down outside of the
theater to record and then I was like oh
it's awfully cloudy and then I just
looked I think we're running low okay
okay we gotta go we're wrapping this up
wrap it up it's good movie yeah
okay we're back at Altamont theater AMC
we're here to see valleys Hellfest it's
like a special kind of like a
conventional American slasher yeah in
the trailer looked something kind of
like remember funhouse
you look buddy Newburgh yeah like
something like that we'll wait to see
what this I don't really like to know
yeah it's about what is it
5:35 4:40 in the afternoon let's see
there's like the theater is really
crowded because I get to see how many
people are in this theater sound like
something going on there's like three
people in here as arrived featuring the
legendary beefy crunch burrito acid
flamin hot Fritos and a million drink
it's the new $2 duo we'll just be in
tacos Alice like we'll get back with you
okay we're gonna give you a quick
lowdown on Hellfest a movie that Jenny
and I saw at the theater a couple days
back that we lost the video review to so
we have to redo it yeah yeah so uh we
saw this thing it's pretty good I'd call
it a classic American slasher almost a
throwback to the 80s done well though
it's a well made flick what'd you say
Jenny it is it seems like it's kind of
like I guess the guy who directed it I
found out later was um he had never
directed before I don't think he had
been an editor he was an editor on get
out which obviously was the big horror
hit of last year which I have not seen
yet so I'll get around to it but this
was kind of like you could tell that he
wanted to do an homage to all the great
eighties slasher movies and also kind of
early 90s a little bit slasher movies
like it gave me yeah screamer I know
what you did last summer type of vibe it
kind of gave me a little bit of that as
well um I don't think it wasn't supposed
to be set back then was it because they
had like modern cell phones yeah [ __ ]
like that but it could have been it
didn't really matter like yeah the
gimmick with this one is that three
couples and of course they're all cute
couples so they go to this thing called
health fest which is kind of like an
amusement park or a convention with a
big horror theme there's all these fun
houses and haunted houses in them and
they go to these places and there's a
stalker stalking them trying to kill
them it's pretty cool so there's murders
happening in fun houses and there's
scares coming from a couple different
directions like you might be scared by
something but it turns out it's just
really just a part of the event of the
funhouse or it might be this guy trying
to who actually did jump out and stab
you you know and security find out about
it but they they don't believe it
because they think it's just part of the
show it's pretty cool it's pretty cool
it's actually a pretty good idea for a
slasher because you can have a slasher
run around cuz essentially what Hellfest
is it's like a traveling carnival I
guess sort of like it looks like
Disneyland yeah it's sort of like
universals Halloween Horror Nights yeah
you know except like a lower budget
version of it but they take up like this
whole thing and there's all these mazes
or houses just like a Halloween Horror
it looks good and some of them are
supposed to be like super EXTREME and so
there's all these like costumed actors
like jumping out on you and the exits
with axes and stuff so it's pretty it's
a pretty good setup for like a slasher
because you don't know is this the guy
or is he a really a murderer is he just
an actor whatever dude that's running
around killing people he's dressed like
staff
yeah he's dressed like there's a lot of
people dressed like right so yeah it's
like you never really know like who's
the real killer and stuff like that um
it's actually it's pretty
straightforward um I was kind of I don't
know like the whole time I watched it I
was almost expecting it to go like meta
you know what I mean like an IDs with
like a Nettie's horror movie you never
really did um it was funny like the
characters were likable they had like a
lot of cute banter and you stuff like
that type of thing a punk rock girl yeah
she was pretty cute yeah and um that's
almost kind of when I first saw her
that's what kind of made me like gave me
the idea that it was supposed to be set
in the eighties but it wasn't because
they have like normal like modern cell
phones and stuff so obviously not but
you know so they just go to this place
and like you know get kind of get picked
off one by one
um what I did offer standard though I
was yeah I was thinking this is well
made but you know I've seen this before
well same crap but as it got as it went
on I was like it started to win me over
yeah I'm like going okay the guys who
did this knew what they were doing
they're [ __ ] with me but it's good
you know I mean it got bad yeah and
towards the end I was smile and I was
enjoying it yeah I'm gonna say like it's
not a groundbreaking horror movie it's
not like it's pretty much a standard 80s
90s slasher set up if you like that type
of thing then you said you know like
it's nothing it's not reinventing the
wheel or anything like that but it's a
perfectly enjoyable if slasher movie for
Halloween if standard was good for the
80s I don't think standard was very good
for the eighties I'd actually put this
into the realm of well made it I think
it is very well made yeah one of the
nicest one of the best things about it I
really liked all of the I mean obviously
a great deal of care it was a tight
script was taken to make the all these
little Halloween mazes like look super
cool the lighting was very cool music
yeah the sound the soundtrack was
actually pretty good
um you know it's you can tell they were
there trying to
maybe a franchise with it or they can
yeah um you know they didn't it didn't
super go over the top with it but you
can see that it's like it they left it
open for that type of thing like this is
gonna be a recurring character recurring
killer type of thing just like Halloween
or scream did so similar kind of thing
go in there and that's it open for that
they did yeah so you know but it's still
like just a standalone like I said I was
almost expecting it to come meta but it
really didn't um it's you know like I
said if you like it reminded me quite
strongly like I said if I know what you
did last summer kind of crossbred with
tobe Hooper's funhouse it was kind of a
similar type of thing going on where
it's like you don't know you know
they're in the funhouse and is that a
real a real corpse or is that like a
fake corpse because everything's
supposed to be fake so it kind of had
that sort of vibe um you know I I don't
know how well it's gonna do because it
seems like I think it's gonna get lost
in the crowd actually I don't you - it's
either people will know how to
appreciate it because actually we
weren't the target audience for this I
think the target audience was a much
younger than us I don't know if they
have what it takes to appreciate a movie
like this actually yeah I think this is
just gonna kind of get lost in the crowd
and let media underestimate them I don't
know but I'm not sure I do kind of feel
young people would actually get the
references yeah
and I do feel like since we're kind of
old and jaded and I've seen like [ __ ]
I've seen 80% of horror movies ever made
yeah so you know it's like I said it's
nothing like spectacular it's it doesn't
do anything different with the genre
it's basically just a loving homage
pretty much to kind of positive it's
very commonly made I'm gonna give it
that I give it a thumbs up just on
competency yeah the quality was good I
thought I thought the quality was very
good like but like you said was it
anything groundbreaking or super
memorable I don't think so no it was
just it was just like a competently made
like an enjoyable
yeah real enjoyable real like I just I
had a good time I have my M&Ms you know
my little caramel M&Ms I'm just like
sitting there it's almost Halloween I'm
like oh it's a slasher movie that's like
kind of has Dario Argento kind of colors
and [ __ ] like that with all that like
super primary colors
who knows I mean for all we know there's
17 and 18 year olds that saw this that
was burned into their mind and from
there I friend it's it's imprinted
deeply and and from here on out they're
expecting this as a standard so you know
what I mean you know what the you know
how do we know yeah I don't wait to see
what happens I mean who would have
thought that Evil Dead one would have
been a classic yeah we would have
thought that any of those movies have
been a classic but when we watch that
again I can see why yeah it's very it's
inventive there was nothing like that at
the time it was the craziest movie so
Hellfest I think I give it a thumbs up
yeah you'll see it it's actually pretty
these that's what you want to see then
you know it's gonna deliver the only
thing that I wish is that it had been
gory er there were a couple scenes there
were a couple good scenes of gore but
they were very quick um you know and I'm
not saying like I'm not super I like
gory movies ideas I think it was a
strategic decision it might have been
they to get a wider audience like yeah
if they made it to if they made it to
torture 43 they felt like it would be -
yeah off putting maybe for all I know
they made Gordon isn't really mom maybe
they made the correct decision maybe it
all depends on what would that I would
have liked it to be a little bit more I
would like it but that's just that's
just me yeah cuz that's just a little
more horrible actually yeah yeah I'm
something something it didn't really
make me feel uncomfortable yeah yeah
that's right like just like when i watch
the other day that was on shudder you
guys and you probably every that's a
horror fan has already seen this by now
I just now got around to it cuz it came
out in 2000 [ __ ] ten but it was I saw
the devil that Korean movie yeah [ __ ]
you guys and as I watched it by myself
like in my office and stuff and it's
like I'm surprised he didn't come in and
see what the [ __ ] was the matter with me
cuz I was in here going oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] like I had to turn away a couple
times and I never do that so that's a
huge plug for that that was [ __ ] up
that was [ __ ] I'm gonna get back to
Hellfest yeah I thought Hellfest is well
made for what it was I think that they
hit the target they were aiming for it
so whether or not that target is
actually there yeah that's the thing
it's about what I expected we win it
I didn't like read anything about it
beforehand which I think I said in the
intro but um you know because I don't
like to you know kind of bias myself I
just like to kind of take the movie on
its own terms and it was about exactly
what I was expecting to get it wouldn't
surprise me if this movie ended up
developing a fandom I mean it probably
will mostly they developed a fandom and
then a sequel came out in the sequels
this was successful I would probably go
yeah I can see that
although I have to say the new Halloween
movie is coming out this year next we
happen to and it will probably ever
shadow this one it looks good I don't
know I don't know how it's gonna go but
then again then you know by experience
or from experience we know that horror
movies often depend upon things like
syndication and and and rentals and time
you know I mean yeah sort of mouths word
of mouth and time so who knows you know
this movie might be very well regarded
in yeah four or five years and might
have sequels and so you know it is it
was what it was I it it achieved its
goals I think yeah like I said I enjoyed
it it was an enjoyable popcorn movie you
take your date I'm called popcorn movie
I don't really don't like that term but
it was a movie you take your young guy
you take your date to and you see little
horror movie and it's and no one's
really offended but it is horribly scary
but you know but it was cool to see the
visuals rehab the music's good it was
entertaining script was tight there
wasn't anything about it that who pissed
me off you know I mean there was nothing
about there was a turn-off um everything
made sense you know talking about yes it
just it was just fun towards the end I
was smiling I was enjoying it you know
yeah I was wondering how see I never
know how he's gonna react we go see
movies I know by the time yeah that last
one he always just kind of sits there
and watches them yeah that last one
third of it I'm going like yeah okay I
know where they're taking me yeah yeah
okay yeah no it wasn't anything new but
I'm pushing 50 we've seen everywhere
everything right I like this better than
that other [ __ ] thing that I saw that
I fell asleep doing with a satanic what
was the name of that one but the girl's
head got whacked off oh I'm sorry oh now
see I loved that movie
his head got whacked off on it I just
look I love that [ __ ] I was like yeah
and people look to me like you're an
[ __ ] and I was like yeah yeah oh I
hated that you know she's that girl I
hated that girl I hated all those
characters and that girl's head got
smashed that is [ __ ] loved it oh yeah
if I smash it seriously I love that
movie although I can't like waking up
when I heard people screaming and
looking and seeing the gags the guys
crawling on the ceilings of [ __ ] I mean
it did do some weird stuff in the very
end but some of the imagery was very
creepy
the imagery oh yeah I enjoyed it I just
didn't like it the problem was is that I
really liked a story that is character
driven that has characters that I like
heredity didn't have any characters I
liked in it so I didn't get it this
movie I would say I liked it better
because I liked all the characters in it
yeah and they got killed I didn't and I
liked all the characters so I must put
this movie above that above I neither
like nor dislike to these characters
they were just there oh come on no they
were but like they were slightly punk
rock girl get killed the [ __ ] black
girl the cute black girl got kill you
it's as cute girls and guys and one dude
they're going trying to fight go down
heroic you know they didn't died anyway
I mean yeah they were yeah they were
kind of generic in a certain way yeah
but the kids watching these are generic
from our point of view so they can you
know we can't tell one from the other
[Laughter]
okay kids you're gonna be just so you
can be in these shoes when these days
you'd be just like I said we were the
same when we were kids I'm never gonna
be like that and now now we're pushing
50 and yeah that was cool
yeah it happens to everyone it's alright
no III thought I thought how fast was
comedy I'm gonna give it I'm gonna give
it I think younger people will probably
enjoy it I think they like their people
like I liked it but I'm just like yeah
see you know it's nothing you haven't
seen before they're old but I thought it
was well made but younger people are
probably digging we're looking at the
genre yeah and the genre I thought it
was you know that whole genre I'm sick
of that whole genre in a certain way
yeah there's not a lot there's no one to
do with Yankee slasher genre like it's
much all been done but I did like the
kind of haunted house asked me yeah but
that was a new angle yeah
farewell fairly get back to fun house
yeah fun house did it - yeah
similar but yeah so if you like that
kind of thing then go check it out if
you don't don't
I don't care do what you want to see on
a list yeah if you've got a MCA list
where you're not really paying they're
not paying us for that seriously it's
just it going up against this for box
office sales I'd probably rather spend
money on something else yeah like if I
had to pay for a ticket I'm gonna pay
for something else then I probably would
have gone to seize nothing else yeah
or I probably would have been like man
it's not bad movies so yeah a petition
is everything else that's going on right
there's just a lot of other ones out
there this this one like I said I agree
with you I think it will probably get
lost in the shuffle it seems like the
reviews are kind of like 50/50 is about
a 50% like some people like yeah it's
alright and some people against and lame
or it's forgettable so you know I feel
like we'll kind of see how it shakes out
but like you said dunno have tails yeah
who knows how people are gonna react
you'll see but anyway that's our review
of health
alright so we just got done with seein
hell faster yeah I would have to say I
think it was a good movie wasn't bad it
was about what I expected
yeah he started off very kind of a
conventional slasher feel to it
you know they established was it three
young couples they're gonna go to this
like an amusement park filled with a
bunch of different fun houses and while
they're there they started getting
stalked by God who's trying to kill him
off one by one
for some reason or another it's not it's
not really explained why I think they
might have been picked at random and
because it's happening it in this
particular location you know sometimes
you're getting confused to whether or
not something is an attraction in one of
the fun houses or if it's really a
threat that's kind of the gimmick of
this to me it felt like I don't know who
directed it I don't know anything about
this movie to me it kind of just felt
like a middle budget well directed well
put together ending film was what it
felt like to me I would say it kind of
felt like it was punching above its
weight in that way the acting was good
character characters were pretty good
and they were all likable there wasn't
anything that you or I could say bad
about the characters conventional about
like you know felt like you're kind of
average slasher
not actually I kind of carry average
good slash you know kind of an 80s for
formula but it also had like some of
that 90s slasher kind of like I know
what you did last summer and that type
of feel to it I kind of a little bit
scream but not just yeah not as ironic
or go home without funny
yeah formulaic it's like you know here's
some college-age kid I'm gonna go you
think was essentially like like a cheap
declaration of universal and Halloween
Horror Nights you know where they just
have like all these super mazes and they
all have different scenes awesome I like
that because I don't remember I mean
other than like we said to be the first
one house that had a similar kind of
premise focus like Affairs and so but it
was the same kind of thing so you're
running around this park and it's like
only people are jumping on you and all
this other yeah and you don't know like
it's a real killer or not and also I
like the aspect of since you signed a
waiver to do this stuff then you know
this about judging really shocking you
and like none of the security guards
believed you could there to do it oh
well it's just that's their job that's
yeah and I so yeah like it was kind of
like like you said the characters were
kind of likeable you know I liked I
liked a lot of the
cinematography it was kind of like I
like all the bright colors yeah it's
kind of like brightly colored lights and
you know they kind of had all the houses
that they went through were like kind of
cool and yeah look just like kind of
like a community theater kind of it was
it was it was well shot too and the Edit
was tight script was good I mean it
really it wasn't really anything I could
complain about this movie yeah it's not
like it's not yeah it was just it's like
a fun it was just Halloween trifle yeah
yeah the good thing to see for Halloween
fun popcorn sex
yeah and done and done correctly it was
I think it was made with love you know I
mean they knew what they were doing they
weren't just slumming through ya you
know that and it wasn't like super gory
but it dug up a couple like just enough
yeah a couple decent scenes that looked
like they were done yeah it didn't look
like CGI and as it went it got a little
bit more suspenseful more suspenseful
got better as it went
it had kind of and but then it became
kind of unpredictable which I kind of
liked that it didn't follow all the
tropes from slasher movies and the
ending was kind of a surprise ending a
little bit yeah I definitely saying that
there's an attempt to try to establish a
series yeah I definitely did get that
feeling especially that one that lack
the last bit
like yeah I just feel like oh wow that's
gonna be like a recurring I think part
of the problem was hurt me and her you
know she's a horror writer and we're
both older I think maybe if we were in
our late teens early 20s who probably
enjoy this movie a lot more because
we've seen a lot of this [ __ ] over and
over again yeah it's like it's like I
said it doesn't do anything now it's
pretty much a standard yeah I feel like
you know a bunch of college-age kids get
a new word on its place and then yeah
and we're not the target market for this
there's not like any crazy big quits
right like that it's like I said it and
I would done and I would definitely say
we're not the target audience in terms
of age really you know get rolled yeah
[ __ ] if I was [ __ ] 1789 yeah yeah
there was some really good shots like
this Redlegs yeah they knew what they
were doing in terms of lighting and
getting shots they got some really good
shots there and some of those chase
scenes with that guy walking in with the
axe and the big laser briefly yeah his
voice yeah yeah he shows them yeah his
voice was in a lot of a team like
Laura's kind of like the master of
ceremonies I thought it was him yeah I
see I thought it was him I'll show ya
okay I'm pretty sure that like it looks
like at the end of the movie there was
like a little Georgia Peach and it said
something about the Georgia film
Association and I'm also pretty sure
that at the beginning might have been
doubt of the producer credit or
something like that I think I saw Gail
and her name in there so I feel like
maybe she
something to do with this or maybe she
got it made or they made it in Georgia
yeah but it's definitely like a really
like I said it's just kind of like a fun
little if you act like a lot of the
nighties type remove like screen type
movie yeah you know it's it's kind of in
that similar vein but not as ironic it's
kind of it's like a nice it's so more
serious yeah sure yeah but with an
eighties area yeah sure like seriousness
yeah like ironic or funny or anything I
liked it it got the job done
yeah in in in in a genre it's good and
like I said it was it was about what I
was expecting yet to be like you know
yes was in no way was it at this
appointment it was yeah it was right
there it was correct for a John Rhett
did with it and there are a lot of
callbacks to the no no it was good yeah
yeah okay
[Music]
you
okay we just got done seeing Benham I
liked it wouldn't you think of a jet
yeah I thought it was quite good
actually it wasn't bad we just had we
had technical difficulties with my
little tablet so we're going to use a
little camera and that we can't get us
both in the shower Sam's house it won't
won't flip around so I'll just kind of
do my review and then Jenny I'll hand
over the camera to make four not before
the time in anyway uh yeah I thought was
a pretty I thought was pretty good I
thought it was better than predator the
I thought the story was tight script is
good there wasn't anything in it that
really annoyed me I think the only the
only thing that kind of disappointed me
is that venom and when he first showed
up you know he made some threats about
other people's heads and killing people
and stacking the heads up in the corners
I really wanted to seem to do that he
didn't do that he did bite some people's
heads off but they didn't really show it
too clearly I understand it's marble you
know but I think it would have been
better had this been a stronger r-rating
it was some gore in it I kind of would
have liked to see the venom cuts of
people's heads off what do you think Jen
yeah he did actually so I like that
there was a very prime example in this
hotel there's lots of lots of
[ __ ] hitting other
[ __ ] with other [ __ ] I
did I did like that part of it I think
the best thing about this from my point
of view like the the look of venom was
really cool and everything yeah I really
really liked Tom Hardy in this role yeah
this is totally different
I really liked him a lot in Mad Max very
bright but this is like a totally
different part for him he's like it's
kind of the schlubby wizard yeah and he
looks very small doesn't it yeah and
this is like you know
it's this alien parasite essentially
like arguing with him up against it oh
yeah I like like a lot of the humor
between him and Ventura I really like
when they're talking to each other and
they're in the same body and it kind of
kind of made me feel better because it
was a Jane that's who's I'm talking to
that's who I'm talking to
it's exactly it's the other one there is
a venom can't come out but no no well
hey this might be able to do some
poltergeist stuff yeah which we've been
having some weird [ __ ] lately or the TV
turning on again mitr society that
happens to be we're going that way yeah
that never reappeared we'll talk about
that later though this was like a pretty
good sort of like you said it wasn't a
lot of it was it was fairly long it's
like two and a half hours but it doesn't
seem like there's a lot of fat - it was
pretty good you know as little
establishing yeah stuff at the beginning
like his emotional state and everything
like that but it didn't spend a huge
amount of time on that yeah back and
forth was like how the aliens got here
and yeah speaking of how aliens got here
do you know did you did you notice that
what they did both predator and venom
both of them had aliens coming here and
they both said that the earth would be
uninhabitable within a generation
because again who paid for that
advertisement do you think they both
said it was one generation that's not
true but they stated it is that as if it
was true which is weird that both of
those movies involved aliens coming to
the earth and Sam to come here maybe
that's what it is
like more of timeframes so it seems like
oh we got it you guys do it now okay
yeah this weird that they did that exact
same one and that except that within a
generation you know I mean it was just
like weird okay
but I don't know I can't really I can't
really think of anything else to say
about the movie uh I don't really like
these Marvel movies that much I think
most of them are pretty vapid this one
was probably one of the better ones that
I saw I think this one actually works
like I said be kind of dark humor yeah
you know the conflict between him and
Venice is like inherently interesting
yeah venom is obviously nailing he wants
to beat people and yeah there was
elements of so I think one of the things
I really liked about this is that there
was an element of monster movie and
sci-fi I think that really would admit
that I think probably coming in a real
close second in terms of Marvel movies
personally ones that I liked a a real
close second would have been that very
first Captain America I kind of liked
that one I'd probably put it on par with
that although we have to say like I
really seen a lot of them I saw the
first couple Iron Man but I'm not like
you know ya know I saw some I saw some
of them on what do you call it uh
Netflix and I watch it for about 15-20
minutes I'm gonna go like why am I
watching this yeah usually just just
stop watching you know I'm not so into
like all the extended universes so yeah
I'm sure Marvel fans are gonna love this
one
I'm sure people who are not Marvel fans
when they see it would like it I think
it's got good ski it's got good
crossover because if you don't like
Marvel at least you have a monster movie
yeah yeah you know what I mean but it's
like
have to have that Brooke you can just
enjoy it like you said it's a monster
movie yeah
anything else you wanna say about yeah
this is a wrap
[Music]